I think one huge mistake,
the gay community and I think of the
American community as a whole has made
is that HIV is a treatable disease and
thus contracting,
it is a nonissue.
And while that may it be the case in
many a HIV positive,
people live long and quote unquote
healthy lives,
uh,
the cost and trauma to that person in
the family.
I wouldn't think anybody would
voluntarily want to sign up for.
Um,
I think there are institutions and you
know,
I,
I do credit and MTV,
which I have plenty of problems about,
but I will give them Kudos for raising
awareness about HIV and getting tested.
Uh,
I think the,
there's a huge part of that equation
missing.
What do you do when you get tested?
It's one thing to walk into a free
clinic and have your blood drawn.
It's another thing for you to be told,
the results that you're positive.
And then there are zero marketing
messages about what goes on there.
And I think that that's a huge dilemma
I'm getting people tested is the first
part,
uh,
beyond that,
it's almost as if that,
that whole possibility has been ignored.
I do think,
especially in New York City,
that the,
uh,
did the use of crystal Meth,
has,
is resurging,
uh,
among young people and that leads to
plenty of unprotected sex.
And I think it is,
you know,
this carefree lifestyle.
But again,
I think it's up to each individual to
really make that call and to protect
themselves.
But there are so many industries out
there that can lend a helping hand.